mucho gusto ILR or Lockett are all that
nosotros papaya for sure 100% all day
every day Hollywood nights yeah you guys
get it now listen my name is Captain Bob
and I am the leader of this group I
don't control you
there's no me toos and this involved
involved in this there's nothing sexual
but I am the leader and I'm your master
but there's no control but your ma
you're a master whatever okay yeah you
get it
I'm a master okay we have here I don't
even know why I do introductions because
I do it every time but we have koloko
kalila AKA we've got the beautiful
Gilbert cuz I always make fun of you
thank you so it's a flat face and all
that kind of stuff I'm not gonna do that
right now you have the beautiful Gilbert
you have the you have a beautiful Thank
You Gilbert
we've got pristine conditioned right up
to par you know ready to go sterile
George Sherrill Georgia no we have the
factory made high quality high quality
George Kimmel a high quality condition
and we've got again me okay the best and
the worst at the same time now I cannot
begin this podcast without bringing up
something that happened the other day
a couple nights ago and I'm there's no
way to tell it I just have to tell it
there's no way to tell it but I just
have to do you get what I'm saying
no right yeah and you don't have to
because I'm traumatized you don't have
to do that right now you're right I'm
sorry
correct me okay come here puppet master
all right so the other day um kalokhe
was mom emeritus and i'm gonna give up
some information she cleans my house on
Sundays can I say that all the time all
the time and she does a great hobby
she's better than Mexicans she's better
she's better than any Mexican robot you
can make in China she goes underneath
she goes above the best she goes in
between it's just her and all the rust
every time she comes over she has to
clean yeah because I'm a nasty [ __ ]
and everyone knows that I've come on the
walls all that stuff mm-hmm
my bad my point is this she's cleaning
we have kalila zom I guess sister she's
my sister not biologically your cousin
she's my yeah she's technically my
cousin but my basically funny
here's her sister this quote-unquote
sister my sister and her two kids are
here my nieces
Jules and Izzy he's about ten and hold
his jewels sixteen she's 16 and she's so
thin she might as well not exist she
might as well just be nothing paper-thin
so I'm in this podcast room because this
is what the room I use when I want to
enjoy a meal and want to get away from
it mm-hmm so I'm watching YouTube videos
I think always watching some bgt they're
just Got Talent I was eating some food
have a good time and this is what I hear
okay I don't get up right away it takes
me a second to absorb the information
that all you're processing it okay right
call 9-1-1 call 9-1-1 mama you know all
that stuff I get up I opened the door
and this is what I see kalila has
Meritus in a Heimlich is it was a move
developed by a guy named Friedrich
Heimlich by in the 1940s I looked it up
right and he was a he's a physician but
he's also it was a chiral a chiropractic
chiropractor back then and he knew the
instrument the body within and basically
Calathes mom who's Filipino had taken a
gigantic ball of rice she swallowed it
it sound like I want to laugh but I was
trauma
I I keep looking at kalila her lips ki
she ate up by the way I made up the for
freedom kinda thing you did
that's not really good all right so I
apologize for the lie okay okay tell the
story she's got a big ball of rice well
a little backstory my mom has a little
form of dysphasia and trouble swallowing
and rice is one of her trigger foods but
she's never had like a real choking
incident in the past she's always just
needed to kind of drink water afterwards
to kind of clear her you know her
esophagus so basically I'm sorry eating
basically Meritus is blue dying
kalila is giving her the Heimlich from
Frederick Heimlich and she's doing it
and she's doing it probably repeatedly
like 4050 times I mean it's like as time
goes on right you know that it's not
gonna be good so she's like I want one
I'm looking around the kids are scream
screaming sister I gonna call her Sir
William Wallace because of her bravery
honey
[Laughter]
sir William Wallace Braveheart
has her body completely turned away from
the situation and mumble and shaking and
mumbling she's a nurse she knows basic
life support but I'm telling you guys
when it's a family member it's a
different feeling and I think I felt the
same way where like even though I sprung
into action and I was doing the Heimlich
I was so emotional on crying at the same
time that I might not have been as
effective as I would have been helping
somebody else and my sisters my sister
who's helped so many people in the past
seriously froze turned around and was
just shaking in a corner
she was just wanting it to be you have a
heart attack or something emergency
happens you don't want honey in this
situation well you do because if she's
not if you're related to her you don't
want her in this year yeah if you're
related to her she cannot help you so
I'd see two phones on the couch now
clasroom screaming at the top of her
lungs call my won-won okay
I look at the at the [ __ ] two phones
on the couch guy can't I don't know
where mine is
come on give me the phone and no one's
give me the phone they're like the phone
no one's give me the [ __ ] phone the
kids are screaming also their phones
don't have American you can't go let me
ask you this though
you can't call nine-one-one on that kind
of phone they only operate on Wi-Fi I'm
not sure actually anyway no one's
handing me the phone
so you didn't have your phone I didn't
know where it was because I didn't know
this was gonna happen
yeah so all of a sudden I find Jules
runs into the bedroom I know she's
sweating and I run in with her and she
hands me
kalila phone we call 9-1-1 and then you
can hear the rice come out like he came
out flung you hit the ground and you all
you heard was I'm calling them all and
also I'm gonna find this lady's name the
[ __ ] what's going on the lady what's
her name what do they call it the
operator that's what you call it yeah
the opera rate how do you say it the
operator is a [ __ ] hunt okay i'ma
call get the ambulance she sir before I
do that I have to ask some questions
first
okay well go ahead don't talk to me like
that sir she said that yeah calm down
right okay go ahead she could tell me
how old is the woman oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
I want to [ __ ] you cows dries out I
don't know
fifty eight okay what's going on call
the ambulance calm down sir okay I'm
calm I mean this is the conversation I'm
having with this woman so two minutes
goes by I trying I'm trying to tell her
what's going on all right
next I called the ambulance next time
you have to just be more calm then I
just hung up on this [ __ ] and if I see
her in the streets I'm gonna punch her
vagina
why her vagina because that's I know how
to do it yeah he knows the technique
yeah I know that that day I gouge I go
underneath the clitoral hood the claw
and I do the clitoral
uppercut yeah they know they know right
Bobby what I do is when I get up there
and I punch right I take my two knuckle
and I cleanse the [ __ ] and I pulled it
out ah right mortal calm you want a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
anyway the ambulance comes at that time
I had already are you crying at that
point or what's going on I'm not crying
I don't cry in situations like that cuz
I'm in full fight-or-flight mode yeah
and I have adrenaline I don't think that
one can cry at that moment but I was I
just like I was so tired because I'm
carrying this like you know adult and
I'm thrusting so much like that
oh my god the best of my ability and
it's not working and at that moment I
felt like such a failure like why isn't
it dislodging and I realize now that
maybe rice is a little bit harder to
dislodge and like maybe a chicken bone
but still like I was so freaked out and
I might be scarred for so the ambulance
come they do their thing they come up
they ask questions should we bring her
this issue at the hospital she seems
fine she's America's gone I'm fine I'm
okay you know they leave I just
basically said Meritage not going home
you're staying here we had to keep an
eye on you yeah and I spent the whole
night I made her sleep in the living
room and I watched her sleep until she
woke up yeah I could not I was so
frightened for my mom and this was
Mother's Day you know like we all watch
a good day it was just [ __ ] scary
I'm in the other room trying to sleep
and I'm thinking what would you think do
you in the other room yeah what would
you think after an event like that
you'd probably be like so much trauma to
know this is what I thought yeah false I
was not which he's shared with my mom so
what kind of Asian doesn't know how to
eat right that's the whole thing it's
like you're Asian you should that's the
one thing you should know I've been
training since its rice right
it's like it's like a Mexican choking on
frijoles you mean or an Italian choking
on spaghetti you should know how to eat
rice lady
all right that's shameful that there's a
flaw in the thing yeah in the gene yeah
but y'all honestly he came out of the
room and he had this like Epiphany right
we were all we were all sitting in that
in the chair yeah and I know it was such
a stressful situation but the moment
he's like Meritus what kind of Asian
does not know how to eat right it was
this is right everyone just like this is
not I'm not doing as a joke by the way
yeah this is like I need to know the
answer we burst out laughing so hard and
it was such like a much-needed like
comedic relief at that moment so at 5:00
in the morning
kalila comes back into my room no it's
like 8:00 8:00 in the morning I can't
sleep I haven't slept the whole time I'm
just laying there
she's leis ex to me and then I closed my
eyes and she's asleep and I just start
weeping I start crying I it was I was so
traumatic I've never been in it to see
her mom blue almost dying right and just
you know it is it it put my life it was
an awakening I had about how fragile
life is and all that stuff and more
importantly my mom is somebody who's so
regimented and because she suffers from
OCD and she has like very like high
anxiety and a lot of fears so her life
is very calculated and she never takes
risks ever
she's when I asked her if she wants to
travel with me she's always like no I
don't fly she doesn't do a lot of things
because she has fear and I told her what
does this tell you you were in the
company of your family you were eating
rice and you almost died I don't care
how what what measures you take to not
die you can die in in in the comfort of
your own home so you might as well start
living and I think it changed your a
little bit she's like you also you just
don't die from eating rice because
that's on your tombstone
right that's how you're remembered okay
car accident right you know a terrorist
attack you know something like that
right
[ __ ] died from eating rice poppy ba ba
ba paid extra thousand I'd spray paint
that on there okay well what's my face
like I might psyche you know what guys
what was traumatic also about it is the
way as time went on she has her mom in
the Heimlich and it's not dislodging and
the you know it just as time goes on the
more panic right and the screaming
people are screaming at the top of their
lungs it was you know it was the most
traumatic thing I've ever seen I've seen
a lot of things but that because I do
love Meritus and obviously I love kalila
and I'm just glad it ended in that way
because in any other way we'd be not
doing this right now yeah we'll never
I'll never be the same
view that that's after I went to Mitzi's
funeral yeah it was right after I went
to meet Mitzi Schwartz funeral and I
spent five hour four hours there and
just in the to witness that oh my god
that's why we're recording on a Tuesday
instead of a Monday yeah because we can
do it like yesterday we just needed time
to decompress and sort of find a way to
make light of it which is really hard
like the turnover cuz I was like okay
like how how do I shake this feeling of
like I just keep running it back in my
head could I have done better could I
been more effective faster less panicked
you know and then we were both feeling
like [ __ ] so what Bobby did which was
like the nicest thing ever is that he
took everybody that was in that room
that day and he took us on Gallivan took
us on a field trip to Little Tokyo and
we had such a blast we went to the
restaurant and I said no rice for her
did I not know I said the waitress and
then we all know
new conditions no rice for that and
they're likely they're Asian to always
we were just watching her true the whole
shoot all Dinah but when we came home it
felt lighter that's felt why but you
know I need one the kids shoes went some
shopping you know there was like a
little that one guy there's one guy
there in the Tokyo Plaza he's you know
he's that one-man band guy yeah you see
you know he has a drum machine and nine
keyboards and he's singing in Japanese I
danced you know yeah I celebrated a life
that day may I say something
yeah go ahead a couple years ago when
there was a woman in need in Seattle
okay
you didn't spring into action and I
remember you saying I'm not gonna call I
don't want to be that person who calls
911 because I don't want to sign papers
and do all that let me just say that you
came through for me so hard if there's a
difference between some random white
lady I don't [ __ ] know yeah alright
and your mom no but you know what like
you could have froze my goodbyes I did
freeze for a second but I could not like
honey no I was like where's the foul
word about you know you were trying and
then when you went I heard you screaming
at the operator yeah yeah yeah you were
my ally in that moment and I don't I'm
trying I think you're trying to give me
props and I'm gonna tell you right now
I'm still a coward I'm still leave I
don't think you're a cat or I bought and
that woman in in Seattle I'll still be
playing candy crush know that know that
I don't know the lady if he doesn't know
you he did not come in here and I might
I don't know but this if that lady in
Seattle would have died it would have
been weird if your mom would have died
it would have been it would have been so
devastating that it's life-altering she
wasn't gonna die not under my watch I
would have kept working and working and
working yeah
and I even if she had passed out I still
would have good done compressions I
would have not stopped and Mitzi's but
Mitzi's funeral was great by the way I
want to talk about that a little bit so
I don't you
to me talk about Mitzi and whatnot but
um they finally had her things Sunday
and um I just talked to Natasha Leggero
and Moshe kasher like an hour a couple
hours ago they were there too as well
and they said something that would they
go that was probably one of the greatest
nights not that Mitzi had died I mean we
got to celebrate her death but just in
terms of like bonding and unity it was
really cool man it was like I sat next
to Jim Carrey uh it was al magical meet
Jim Carrey
Kevin Christie Whitney Cummings Natasha
everyone was are in our area and you you
got to see all the legends go up and
talk about Mitzi because I'm from a
later generation so they were telling
stories from the 70s and 80s and um it
was Jimmy Walker Yakov Smirnoff dice
Mike binder I mean all these guys and it
was um it was insane and I saw some
people that I didn't want to see but
that was like neutral ground you know
that was neutral ground and it was a
really cool you know it was a mix of
like Superstars and open mic errs and it
was a really cool night and it made me
realize that um at the end of the day
I've had an amazing life I mean this did
her mom was the thing you know you just
kind of reflect and you go my life it's
so amazing and I don't really you know
sit there and appreciate it because you
know I have that ISM the thing that once
more and where's mine and [ __ ] that guy
and all that stuff and I don't know if I
want to live like that anymore I I think
that you know these two events in one
day it just kind of you know put a
perspective on things
[Music]